[Music]
[Music]
to all our amazing fans the truth is we
are here for you we got to thank you for
10 years of support and inspiration the
reason we're here
thank you for 10 years of your greatest
cosplay
standing in those long lines for Hall
age reading the comics after you saw the
movie Twitter fights and it's all been
leading up to this thank you please just
thank you so much thanks for being so
incredible you couldn't have done any of
this without you
read it run from it
the end is near
we're gonna need some help how you been
buck not bad for the end of the world
[Music]
I'm Dara don't fight for one
we fight for all of them
Avengers infinity war when you said we
were going to open what conduct to the
rest of the world this is not what I
imagined
or give you imagine the Olympics maybe
even a Starbucks everywhere April 27 a
powerful threat goals for a greater
response
when there is a battle bring strength
[Music]
when there's a problem
seek answers when there's doubt
give hope
not tomorrow
not in a few years
but right now joining Marvel Studios
adventures Infinity Ward and American
Airlines in this fight today
donate $25 or more you'll receive ten
American Airlines advantage miles for
every dollar you give visit stand up to
cancer org slash American Airlines to
learn more together we can save lives
you